[Musique]
alors oui
j'en ai de la fierté
et je les ai eus les larmes aux yeux
lorsque j'ai su que j'entrai dans cette
prestigieuse école
les rires
les fleurs
les sourires de mon grand-père dont la
petite fille faisait de brillantes
études et puis je vais pas vous mentir
le soulagement aussi ouf j'y suis arrivé
pendant deux ans on m'a dit que je ne
saurais pas que je ne valais pas que je
ne pourrais pas mais regardez moi
alors oui
j'en ai de la fierté
et pourtant
comment ignorer cette sensation violente
profonde
cette impression terrible que
c'est pas là ma place
comment ignorer cette impression quand
tout autour de moi vont en amphit en TD
en cours avec un grand sourire aux
lèvres ou du moins l'impression de faire
quelque chose de bien
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs le drame de
ma vie je me débrouille en maths et en
physique et voilà le résultat je fais
des maths et la physique mais j'ai pas
voulu ça
et ses pensées ces mots
c'est tous ceux qui traversaient la tête
de Inès 21 ans il y a maintenant
quelques mois
c'était une espèce de d'idées brouillon
de sensation de malaise un peu dans le
fond de son esprit
comme une grosse boule entremêlées dans
laquelle elle avait peur d'aller se
plonger
mais aujourd'hui avec vous
j'ai envie d'aller chercher un petit peu
la cause de ce mal-être
j'ai envie de
oser plonger dans ce truc qui fait peur
parfois
et à les poser les mots sur l'origine de
ce malaise
et pour faire ça il faut partir deux ans
auparavant rencontrer Inès 19 ans
qui finit sa classe préparatoire
alors peut-être que certains d'entre
vous ici ne savent pas ce que c'est les
classes préparatoires je vais vous la
faire courte c'est l'enfer
bon peut-être pas en tout cas ces deux
ans voire trois pour les plus chanceux
où on travaille dur pour avoir l'école
de son choix sur concours
et pour connaître un peu cette Inès qui
est là il faut savoir pourquoi elle
atterrit dans une classe préparatoire
en fait elle est pas venue pour une
école en particulier elle n'avait pas un
but en tête ce qui lui plaisait dans
l'idée des classes préparatoires c'était
la manière de travailler
ce dépassement de soi aller voir jusqu'à
jusqu'où on peut aller c'est ça qui
c'est ça qui lui faisait plaisir c'est
ça qu'il a poussé à entrer dedans
et en fait elle a eu de la chance parce
que au cours de ces deux ans justement
elle s'est découvert une passion une
passion pour la chimie
pourtant
je suis là devant vous et je vous parle
en tant qu'élève ingénieur des Ponts
donc il y a eu un petit problème quelque
part
et en fait ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que
cette Inès 19 ans elle travaillait
elle était là pour travailler et elle
avait pas réfléchi à ce qui allait se
passer après l'échéance de ses concours
alors
quand le moment est venu et qu'on lui a
dit voilà à présent ton but est atteint
tu peux faire un choix elle était
complètement perdue
et ce qu'il faut comprendre aussi c'est
que
si on peut avoir l'illusion de
travailler pour avoir le choix de son
école ensuite on se rendrait vite compte
de ce qui se passe réellement dans ces
classes préparatoires en fait au final
quand on a le mieux on prend le mieux
et ça ça lui est rentré dans la tête et
finalement c'est ce qu'elle a fait à la
fin elle a fait le choix responsable le
choix sérieux elle a eu le mieux elle a
pris le mieux
et je pense que ce que je vous raconte
là ça peut un peu se rapporter un
dilemme qu'on connaît tous choix de cœur
choix de raison
on a tous je pense déjà été confrontés à
des choix pareille
mais à ce stade de ma réflexion
j'étais pas satisfaite si cette espèce
de Dilemme représentait bien ce qui
s'était passé j'avais pas l'impression
d'avoir expliqué les raisons pourquoi
avoir fait ce choix de raison
et peut-être que pour certains
peut-être que pour certains faire un
choix de raison c'est quelque chose qui
leur suffit pour expliquer les parcours
qu'ils ont pris
mais moi ça me satisfait pas
et j'ai dû continuer cette introspection
pour aller chercher les raisons un peu
plus profondes encore
pour faire ça il faut repartir encore en
arrière et aller rencontrer une NES qui
est encore plus jeune
celle-ci elle a 17 ans
et vous la connaissez déjà un petit peu
elle se débrouille en sciences elle aime
bien ça
mais c'est pas ce qu'il a fait vibrer
et cette Inès pour bien la connaître
je dirais que ce qu'il a caractérise
quand elle est en terminale et qu'elle
doit faire ses choix
ce qu'il a caractérise c'est que
elle se la pète un petit peu
elle dit à tout le monde moi je ne serai
pas lâche
je ferai pas le choix de la facilité je
n'irai pas en prépa scientifique
encore une fois il y a un truc qui s'est
mal passé
bon alors je pense que vous voulez tout
savoir qu'est-ce qui se passe dans sa
tête si c'est pas ça qu'il a fait vibrer
c'est quoi et bien Inès 17 ans ça
passion c'est les lettres
elle est complètement fan de littérature
et si et si elle apprécie et qu'elle
admire ses professeurs de mathématiques
ou de physique elle adulte complètement
ses preuves de français à être philo et
c'est les gens qu'elle regarde dans la
vie ce vers quoi elle veut tendre c'est
justement des gens de lettres c'est ça
qu'elle a envie de faire
et là je pense que vous devenez que vous
devinez tous un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé
en général ce qu'on met dans la tête
d'un élève qui est fort en sciences et
qui a les moyens d'aller se débrouiller
dans ce qui est le plus valorisé
qu'est-ce que tu irais faire en
littérature tu as la chance d'être fort
en maths la question de se pose pas
et en fait
à ce moment là
cette Inès
elle avait conscience elle avait
conscience un peu de ce dilemme cœur
raison comme je vous ai parlé
mais ce qu'il a vraiment poussé c'était
justement ce regard des adultes autour
d'elle
il fallait être responsable être logique
faire le choix sérieux pourquoi
l'esthéré en lettres alors qu'on a un
autre avenir devant soi qui paraît un
tout petit peu plus brillant ou joyeux
et donc voilà elle a fait ce choix là et
puis en fait je pourrais continuer à
vous faire des tableaux encore et
remonter dans dans cette introspection
ou dans mon histoire
mais pour la faire courte plus je
remontais les tableaux de ma vie et plus
je me plus je me rendais compte que un
même schéma revenait une même idée sans
cesse
l'envie désespéré d'être prise au
sérieux
et par exemple je vais vous en donner
qu'un seul la liste serait trop longue
on va prendre Inès 9 ans elle est en CE2
si je dis pas de bêtises
elle aime bien l'école elle aime bien
elle est en classe elle adulte sa
maîtresse comme beaucoup d'élèves qui
aiment bien aller en cours
et elle a la chance de se faire prêter
un livre par sa maîtresse Les Misérables
version pour enfants je vous rassure
et depuis ce moment-là elle a des
moments de connivence avec sa prof quand
on parle de livre ou quand on est en
classe de français elle lui jette des
petits regards et elle se sent écoutée
elle voit que le simple fait qu'elle
puisse s'intéresser à des choses des
choses de grand ça lui donne un cachet
que les autres élèves n'ont pas et elle
devient complètement accro à ça
et en fait si aujourd'hui c'est ces
sensations qui pour moi explique
certains choix que j'ai pu faire
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à me rendre
compte que c'était peut-être la de là
que venait le problème
parce qu'en réalité ces sensations elles
étaient surtout positives c'était la
fierté de rendre ses parents le bonheur
de rendre ses parents fiers plutôt le ce
contact qu'elle avait avec ses
professeurs cette envie d'aller à
l'école et cette positivité constante
comment ça aurait pu être la source d'un
problème plus tard
mais voilà
aujourd'hui
après avoir voulu justement
à les mettre les mots sur le malaise que
moi aujourd'hui j'ai pu ressentir
je me suis demandé pourquoi c'était
que maintenant en fait que je pouvais me
rendre compte et que et que je voulais
me détacher de cette idée de sérieux qui
a trop longtemps gouverné mes choix
et en fait
j'ai compris
je suis là
je les ai coché toutes les cases de
légitimité j'ai coché toutes les cases
de choses qu'il fallait faire dans sa
vie
et je me sens enfin légitime
ici à l'École des Ponts je me sens enfin
légitime de dire
bah non
enfin j'ai pas envie d'être ici
et c'est bête mais moi ça m'a pris tout
ça ça m'a appris tout ça pour enfin me
laisser choisir sans être trop soumise
au regard des autres
à l'envie de faire quelque chose qui va
m'apporter peut-être de l'écoute ou du
respect
moi ça m'a pris d'être là et pour
d'autres ça leur prendra un poste un
certain travail autre chose je sais pas
certains n'auront jamais besoin d'avoir
cette prise de conscience mais si
aujourd'hui je suis là devant vous
c'est un peu pour vous questionner là
dessus
ça m'a pris d'être ici mais vous ça vous
prendra quoi et si aujourd'hui je
pouvais parler justement à toutes ces
Inès qui ont fait des choix si
importants et pour des raisons
qui ne sont pas les miennes
si je pouvais leur parler je leur dirai
c'est vous qui avez le sérieux de votre
vie entre vos mains et vos choix vous
devez les placer là et vous écouter
et si j'ai dû me réapproprier cette
notion de sérieux pour mettre en lumière
un malaise que je pouvais avoir dans ma
vie
peut-être que pour d'autres
ce sera je ne sais pas l'envie d'être le
meilleur
l'envie de rendre fière des choses qui
peuvent s'en rapprocher
pour moi
ça a été le sérieux mais pour vous
ce sera quoi
merci
[Applaudissements]